[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
you know you did something right when
the entire right Wing manga
apparatus is absolutely pissed
this morning
a bunch of bigots on the floor of the
house
spewing and puking up their [ __ ]
bigotry because they don't want other
people to marry who they love
that's why they don't like this Brittany
Greiner thing that's why
well there's two three reasons she's a
woman she's black and she's a lesbian
tell me different
tell me different
if this was a straight white man being
traded for this prisoner to come home a
basketball player
they'd be up be exciting so exciting
nope black black gay woman nope
just lever lever to Putin
that's what it is I mean how great of a
victory is it that the Biden
Administration and the United States
government and the state department
has managed to get Brittany Greiner home
and the reaction from the rights like oh
let her rot in a Russian prison
because that's what that's what they
want
for black gay women in general not not
just ones in Russia
it's disgusting but if you expected
anything above the bar of disgusting
from these [ __ ] you have not
been paying attention and neither have
they really
neither have they
and that's where we're winning this the
every single battle
that democracy is fighting we're winning
every [ __ ] one of them I know it
feels like that we're on our heels and
fascism is here it's here and they're
they are a threat
foreign but we're winning
it's because of you it's because
democracy
ultimately
delivers
equity and equality
it takes time it's work it's not easy
none of this stuff is easy
if you think we're gonna unwind
thousands of years and really hundreds
of years in this country
a bigoted history
and white institutionalism
that ain't gonna happen overnight
it's going to be hard work
but if you think white supremacy and
fascism is the way that you're going to
unwind that institutionalism in this
country you're [ __ ] out of your mind
that's what they want to [ __ ]
solidify and codify it
Vicki Hartzler she's a representative
from the state of Missouri she's a pile
of [ __ ] garbage
it's crying crying on the house floor
this morning I'm gonna show you [ __ ]
clip this is ridiculous
crying on the house floor because they
can't they can't force someone
to marry who they want them to marry
you talk about [ __ ] groomers are you
[ __ ] me you're telling me that
somehow your life is affected when
someone else is marrying the person they
[ __ ] love regardless of the genitalia
or the sexuality you people are are you
[ __ ] are headed down a road
where you're not gonna get a say in
anything
if you don't stop the bigotry
and crying over it sobbing
oh I I want my colleagues to vote
against equality she literally said she
wants her colleagues to vote against
equality
I've been telling you that they're
saying the quiet part out loud and their
bigotry is right out there to see
again what do you think this Britain
Greiner thing is
Trump trump [ __ ] released 4 000
Taliban members invited them to Camp
David like come come negotiate with us
on our [ __ ] soil at a sacred place
and I'll release thousands thousands of
Taliban members
and they're and they're [ __ ] upset
because the bite Administration
negotiates the release of Brittany
Greiner Who had who had residue
in Russia
it's because she's a black gay woman
prove me [ __ ] wrong
show me the [ __ ] evidence show me
show me where it's so egregious that we
do a prisoner swap to make sure an
American citizen who did not do what
they accused her of doing comes back
home with her [ __ ] family
the only sad part about this is Biden
wasn't an abiding Administration in the
state department was not able to
negotiate any other prisoner swap
we used to we used to cheer when
Americans came home
regardless of your you know your
political affiliation
this used to be a moment of patriotism
where an American citizen who was
wrongly [ __ ] convicted in a foreign
country especially one ran by our enemy
and a murderous [ __ ] dictator like
Vladimir Putin
who is the enemy of democracy
democracy is what will stop him from
existing
that's why he wants to tear down any
democracy he can
and we bring her home
and somehow it's a bad thing
you just just try just try to [ __ ]
convince me that that they [ __ ] hate
Brittany Greiner for no other reason
than she's a black gay woman
they don't they don't care about what
she did or didn't do what was accused of
doing what was wrong and convicted for
they don't give a [ __ ] that she's a
basketball player and she's a she's a
famous person they don't give a [ __ ]
just like when when and if fascism takes
over here in this country Kanye West
you're one of the first [ __ ]
you know that
Nick Fuentes you're one of the first
[ __ ]
if you let them do what you want them to
do
you stupid [ __ ]
but all these are victories of democracy
folks yesterday
Reverend Raphael Warnock wins in Georgia
because because of turnout
people crawling to the polls and it's
not Warnock is a good Senator good
I I wouldn't put him as one of the
greatest
he does his job well which is what you
would expect of an incumbent
he seems to have lived a Christian moral
life which you think that would matter
to the right
and his opponent Herschel Walker can
barely work his way out of a wet paper
[ __ ] sack
foreign
has had his hand held his entire life
and he's done the whole token black
thing
his entire [ __ ] life
so good for him
but that requires that that is not the
bar that is set
for the United States Senate and
yesterday democracy spoke
what do you think it was I said more
than anything the 51 votes yet was
important making sure Democrats have the
majority in the Senate yeah really
[ __ ] important in this point
of where our government's at seeing that
the house is going to concentrate on
nothing but dick pics of Hunter Biden
super important but more than anything
the message was the most important thing
to tell the [ __ ] manga Republicans
the American Nazi party to [ __ ] off
and we have to keep sending this message
and the reason is clear you can see it
in the Brittany Griner story
clear as day
and the reason again the reason why they
do not want Brittany Greiner traded is
because she's a black gay woman
that's that's why
it's another one of the others coming
back in our country that's how they
[ __ ] feel
and we must not relent
crying on the floor of the house
crying
pleading for her colleagues to vote
against
equality
you got it you understand
are you seeing it now
this is one lonely [ __ ]
representative from the state of
Missouri who couldn't even get a senate
campaign off the ground
I went to a
Fourth of July parade Vicki Hartzler
is in my district
Vicki Hartzler had a float
quote in the parade
it was literally some bang dance [ __ ]
second-hand U-Haul truck that she
painted her name on the side of it that
was it no Flyers no people walking
no music just a old busted up [ __ ]
U-Haul second-hand U-Haul
that probably is carried around Patriot
front and other Nazis to other events
where they want to protest equality and
equity and that was it
a joke
a [ __ ] joke
and as bad as the scene was at the
parade of the old busted up [ __ ]
U-Haul with her name painted on the side
of it Vicki Hartzler does something even
more [ __ ] pathetic
which is go on the floor of the house
and cry
for her colleagues to vote against
equality
and everyone's standing around wondering
why the former president of the United
States is calling for the Constitution
to be terminated
the same reason why Maga is upset that
Brittany Greiner is coming home
they're [ __ ] Nazis they're [ __ ]
bigots
they are not Patriots they are not they
are not patriotic Americans they do not
give a [ __ ] about the flag the
Constitution the military our government
the people their constituents they do
not give a [ __ ]
foreign
until you really do the math and come to
terms with that
media
that's
the main folks that have not done the
math on this yet
you were not you were not going to look
through the lens correctly
it's just not going to happen
well there are some that are not wanting
to [ __ ] that [ __ ] if you're if you're
still having an R next to your [ __ ]
name you are a Nazi
Mitt Romney
I played your clip the other day Mitt
Romney says we're the party of the
Constitution
where the party is with Constitution
well answer me this Mitt Romney how do
you explain Vicky Hartzler crying
begging and pleading for her colleagues
to vote against equality
well it's marriage equality marriage
between a man and a woman that's what
you believe that's what you want so go
do that no one is telling you you can't
have a marriage between a man and a
woman no one's saying that you
[ __ ]
no one's telling you what your beliefs
can and can't do I don't give a [ __ ] how
you spin it how you [ __ ] try to
package it up that they're trying to
make you gay
no one is trying to force you into gay
marriages no one
you're trying to force people to be
straight dummy
that's because you're a fascist go look
it up dust off the [ __ ] dictionary do
a little bit of a little bit of looking
up
just five [ __ ] minutes just ten maybe
three maybe three
to figure out what the [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
the majority of Americans do not
the majority of Americans do not
want people telling them who they can
and who they can't marry who their
neighbors can and can't marry who their
[ __ ] friends can and can't marry who
complete [ __ ] strangers candy can't
remember I told you the other day
I I really don't care if people want to
be in a marriage with three or four
people that's their [ __ ] business as
long as it's consensual an adult
and that's you know the other thing they
have trouble with
the underage thing they're really
obsessed with that
wonder why
Matt Walsh wants to make sure he
captures every Every Woman
while every underage girl in a marriage
before she becomes a woman so that way
there's no chance there's no chance
that's that's what they want
but that's the reason why they're
freaking out this morning about Brittany
Greiner she's a black gay woman and
she's coming back to our country
she is an other that is how they feel
deep down inside their core I don't give
a [ __ ] what book They're reading what
church they go to what morals they say
they have what God they're praying to
what Constitution they do and don't say
they believe in
you are a [ __ ] bigot if you if you
even
have any kind of inclination deep down
inside of you that you want to force
someone to not marry the a person that
they love
because you're freaked out you it's a
you problem [ __ ] you have a
problem with their genitalia
and their gender
as if it's if it's any your [ __ ]
business
and that's why they're absolutely pissed
off
and about an American basketball player
being traded
for another Russian prisoner
really honestly whoever we trade to
Putin isn't going to last long anyways
this guy can't even hold a [ __ ] fart
without [ __ ] himself apparently you
can't walk down a set of stairs Vladimir
Putin is who I'm talking about
I don't know when we're gonna when we're
gonna wake up to the news that he has
eaten an ammo sandwich
but his days are not long
so anyone we train trade to the Russian
regime
is not favorable for them
and I'm going to show you some of their
reaction and some of their responses
this morning
not just to the Brittany Greiner thing
because
hell man to watch their reaction to of
an American citizen coming home
after being wrongly convicted ridiculous
conviction in a Russian Court
and of course Donald Trump Jr saying see
this is why they did it
so you would trade
as if the Biden Administration just woke
up yesterday and started talking to
Russia about trying to get Brittany
Greiner home get the [ __ ] out of here
with that nonsense this has been months
in the making
months in the making
so this idea that somehow this was just
a a decision on a whim is really [ __ ]
dumb
and really Newt Gingrich is right when
he says that manga is totally
underestimating Joe Biden here
and I don't want to give him exactly too
much credit because I know there was a
whole team of people at the state
department and in the administration
that worked their asses off
to communicate with Russia
to get Brittany home
but who do you who do you think directed
that
who do you who do you think has been
under this pressure before
why do you think that Joe Biden
in our modern history
in 20 30 40 years from now we're gonna
look back and go God damn
he was an effective [ __ ]
an effective [ __ ]
he may not be the most eloquent he may
have a stutter
he he may be old
and walk a little light
he may be a career politician and he may
not have the exact
ideas that you have
or the exact outcome that you were
hoping for
and I don't brag about the [ __ ]
on this show a lot I just don't
I don't feel like we have to be a cult
to [ __ ] anybody
we do not have to [ __ ] wear biting
hats and Biden stickers and it'd be our
entire [ __ ] personality
because we love democracy and freedom we
do not have to do that
but credit where credit is due Joe Biden
is an effective [ __ ] president
an effective [ __ ] president
and Maga be damned
like he's not getting any help from the
fascist
and he's still effective
it's one thing that uh President Biden
has learned in his years
in D.C in the government
he knows who to turn to
he knows who to have on the team if you
want to get something accomplished
and you got a goal you got an insight
he's going to tell you
exactly what you need to probably get
there
rather it's possible or not I mean I get
you know that's the question
but the effectiveness of Biden and the
Biden Administration is clear
Trump would have had to trade another 5
000 Taliban to get Brittany Greiner home
yeah and he would have
he would have
[ __ ] he gave he gave thousands of
prisoners Taliban prisoners terrorists
just so he could try to get credit for
Afghanistan
and then when his plan flopped because
it was his [ __ ] Exit Plan
the United States government and the
United States military and the dod just
had to [ __ ]
implement the plan that they put in
place when it flopped I don't want
credit for that
so we'll blame it on Biden
when in theory and reality
the exit of Afghanistan even with the
shitty ass plan that the Trump
Administration put in place
the Biden Administration made it very
effective one of one of the quickest and
largest exits from a war zone
you'd imagine that
Joe Biden is effective
again
I don't want to be accused
I'm simping for Biden
but you gotta hand it to the guy
and he deserves credit on this one
Brittany Greiner
yeah you may not like me for that but
and [ __ ] you
the reason why Brittany Greiner is on
her way home right now which is where
she should be is at home in this country
with her [ __ ] family
[ __ ] the basketball thing that can come
later
wouldn't you want your family member
here
your sister your daughter
your mother
your granddaughter wouldn't you want
them back here
wouldn't you
safe with their family
to sit around at the holidays drink hot
cocoa
watch movies
spend time
that's what this [ __ ] used to be about
you know that
that's what this [ __ ] used to be about
they've destroyed everything
that's what they do they destroy
absolutely everything
even a victory like getting Brittany
Greiner home they [ __ ] just
absolutely destroy it
because that's their brand
so I want to I want to say
welcome home Brittany and you spend time
with your family
I know it's probably been a crazy
[ __ ] time
in your incarceration so take the time
and spend that with your family let that
basketball stuff
come later and welcome home you deserve
to be here you should be here
with your family
and anyone who says anything different
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em [ __ ] em everybody
today is Thursday and you know every
Thursday we vote on bonehead of the week
and I'm sure I'm sure one of these
[ __ ] Brittany grinder digs is going
to be a bonehead I'm almost positive
and they're going to get worse and worse
as the day goes on oh yeah they're gonna
be like oh well that one was bad but let
me see if I can get a shittier one
100 percent that's what's gonna happen
so make sure you you follow us on
Twitter
as long as it's still over there at Tony
Michael's pod you can vote for bonehead
of the week there this evening you can
also vote on our YouTube channel
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
on YouTube go to the community tab just
click the community tab the poll will be
there also download every single episode
why not I know you listen to it on
YouTube but do us a favor even if you
just go over and download it listen to a
few minutes that would help out a lot
a ton Apple Spotify Google your favorite
directory and why you're there
subscribing
leave us a great review why you're there
I know you love the show and you know
what if you hate the show leave a review
too and we got plenty of trolls leaving
reviews go follow us on Facebook as well
I know you're listening from the mind is
touch Facebook page go follow our
Facebook page at the Tony Michaels
everyone stick around we're gonna go
through the [ __ ] let's round up I'm
going to show you some of these
reactions now these [ __ ] bigots on
the house floor to the uh the marriage
the respect The Marriage Act where
they're begging begging and crying to
get their colleagues to vote against
equality I'm not [ __ ] you that is
that is the words that they're saying
out loud into a [ __ ] microphone on
the official record of the house floor
everyone stick around
be right back right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
shitless Roundup coming up
surfing the Tweety tweets and training
trends
I got a private message yesterday from a
friend who listened to the show and he
said man you were talking about man
men's [ __ ] a lot yesterday I'm like
look I I have to tell you these people
are absolutely obsessed with genitalia
I I just I [ __ ] just come here and
commentate on what's going on what do
you want me to do I don't I don't get to
decide what people are [ __ ] doing and
just commentate on it I just tell you
what the hell
you should be paying attention to and
you should definitely uh be paying
attention to their obsession
they're weird obsession
with other people's genitalia and that's
what this [ __ ] is about on the house
floor this morning
I'm dead serious that's what this stuff
is about their bigotry on the house
floor
on the respect to Marriage Act
that that that's what they [ __ ] hate
about Brittany Greiner
is she's got a wife
they got the same genitalia I just can't
tolerate that
as if it's any of their [ __ ] business
they're sick they're twisted
they can't see the beauty and two people
loving each other what the [ __ ]
where's your [ __ ] Humanity for crying
out loud oh that's right you ain't got
any never had it they ain't got it
why are we standing around waiting on
them to [ __ ] develop characteristics
like decency
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
if they want to be vile pieces of [ __ ]
let them be let's just move on and let's
go and do the thing that democracies do
and put people in power that can create
policies that will move forward and if
they want to live in the [ __ ] past
let them [ __ ] live in the past that's
your right that's their freedom in this
country if you want a whole bigot of
views fine whatever but you do not get
to press them on everyone else you do
not get to tell us with your religion
what the [ __ ] we are and aren't gonna do
and who we're gonna love and who we want
to marry because we love and really
frankly most people in this day and age
understand that marriage is kind of
[ __ ] anyways
it's more of a legal contract so you can
have legal means
the [ __ ] does marriage marriage doesn't
mean love for crying out loud
look at Donald Trump how many [ __ ]
times has he been married look at
Marjorie Taylor green why is she getting
divorced if it's so [ __ ] sacred
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
it's a stupid legal contract that allows
people to do certain things
and buy certain material and have
certain permissions when it comes to
Health Care choices and finances that's
it
as if marriage is some kind of sacred
[ __ ] Union between a man and a woman
get the [ __ ] out of here Love Is Love
[ __ ]
and if it's 2022 and you don't
understand that fine whatever keep it to
your [ __ ] self
keep it to your [ __ ] self
that's all I'm saying
I thought that was the [ __ ] American
thought that that was our national
Collective like I said yesterday stop
telling us what the [ __ ] to do
and when to do it and who to do it with
we got a lot of stuff to round up
because I want to show you these you
gotta see these responses on the floor
of the House of how they're talking
about American people
they're talking about American people
here they're talking about their [ __ ]
constituents
this is vile gross [ __ ] the [ __ ] they're
saying
it's [ __ ] disgusting
that they that they absolutely do not
want
American people loving who they want to
love
they want to force them
to not do something
and then and then the gross [ __ ] vile
thing that they do is to turn the LGBT
community into the Predators that they
are
the projection of their predatory ways
on the LGBT community is [ __ ] gross
vile
and I don't know who this representative
good is I'm going to show you a video
him but he starts talking about [ __ ]
bestiality and stuff let me tell you
something if there's going to be a [ __ ]
Committee in the House of
Representatives we need to see Mr Good's
laptop I think
anyone who's on the floor of the house
saying bestiality has anything to do
with the lgbtq community we need to
check that motherfucker's electronic
devices and now
if you are coupling those two things
together there is something about you
that you're projecting to us
that your constituents may need to know
I'm just saying representative good you
piece of garbage you [ __ ] vile piece
of trash
bringing bestiality into it on the
[ __ ] house floor when you're talking
about marriage
you gross son of a [ __ ]
I'm gonna show you the clip I'm gonna
show it to you it's [ __ ] gross but
you need to see what these [ __ ]
are saying about Americans
they're talking about their countrymen
it's [ __ ] disgusting absolutely
[ __ ] disgusting and I know Gabe
Sanchez agrees with me on this and I I
can almost bet when I ask him about
Brittany Greiner the reason why they are
[ __ ] just pissed off
that she's coming home is because she's
a black gay woman and ain't got nothing
else to do with it Gabe Sanchez what do
you say I think that is spot on I mean
uh here's the thing today I would say is
a win there are two wins yep in both of
those groups right you've got the uh the
marriage equality act that came through
right and you've also got Brittany
Greiner who in in both scenarios you've
got people of under same-sex marriage
and also interracial marriage and you've
got someone who is of the lgbtqia
community and who's also black so I
think there's a lot of outrage that is
going on uh from the uh from the right
and we we also need to remember that
we've got people like Don you know Don
Jr and other people [ __ ] up in arms
and saying oh that's a fair trade oh
let's not forget whose father traded 5
000 Taliban soldiers wait wait wait who
what is the Taliban by the way just
remind me just remind me who the Taliban
I don't know like this they're like this
organization that they have a big T I
think it's terrorist organization oh
yeah you mean you mean you mean the one
that we had a 20-year useless war with
is that the one I mean yeah exactly and
so that was that is what's happening
today you have all of them being like Oh
No let me tell you this is [ __ ] this
trade is so unfair this arms dealer yeah
it's not great that we're giving
obviously an arms dealer but also at the
same time if you were to compare it to
someone in the last Administration
incompetent saying hey we're going to
trade 5 000 [ __ ] Taliban terrorist
soldiers
for a thousand on the other side as it
was quoted I would bet I would bet Trump
would trade five thousand more Taliban
members to keep Brittany Greiner in
Russia probably that [ __ ] piece of
trash and every single one of these
[ __ ] that are saying just vile
gross bigoted [ __ ] on the house floor
today and again like you said these are
victories but and we should celebrate
them but folks you cannot look away at
what they're saying about these
victories and how they view them through
the through the [ __ ] lens of of
America for crying out loud it's [ __ ]
weird ass [ __ ] that that Vicky Hartzler
and I'm gonna show you this [ __ ] clip
she is on the house floor crying begging
her colleagues to vote against equality
she says those [ __ ] words
you know I I literally just watched that
clip and I'm like I'm sorry that you're
bigoted religious views can't be
oppressed onto other people if you want
to look you want to cry all you want
that's totally fine are you a bigoted
snowflake who can't accept that there's
other forms of love that exist not
between just a man and a woman like also
Clarence Thomas can go [ __ ] himself for
even floating the idea after Roe Roe v
Wade that we should even look at things
like same-sex and interracial marriage
so the Republican Party can cry all they
[ __ ] want but all of them are [ __ ]
snowflakes I'm sorry that you want to
say a gay couple can't get a [ __ ]
cake and a gay couple can't get married
and you're so upset that a that a uh I
think Britney Griner has two Olympic
gold medals I believe is what it is and
someone can fact check me in the in the
comments here but I'm pretty sure the
fact that not only
is she black is she gay uh and and
successful athlete she's a [ __ ]
Patriot right she she plays for [ __ ]
USA there's nothing more patriotic than
winning gold medals for your Country
Wide athletic event well these these
these are the [ __ ] that voted
against
voted against non-citizens becoming
citizens because of their military
service just what was it yesterday of
the day before yeah we forgot to mention
that I mean Jesus Christ we ain't got 12
hours to [ __ ] go through every single
piece of dumb [ __ ] that these people
put out but they do every [ __ ] day
they voted against military people who
joined the military becoming citizens
it's [ __ ] great people who are not
American willing to put their life on
the line for a country that they hope
will accept them but you have this weird
[ __ ] bigoted racist uh that's all it
is what it is it's what it is man well
here's the thing and I said this in the
first 30 minutes if if Joe Biden was
trading for a white man straight man who
is a basketball player who had the same
[ __ ] credentials as Brittany Greiner
they would be like Yay good job nope not
not this morning
um what is this this image that season
so this is a tweet that that Caitlyn
sent me okay
um which is you know of course you've
got the right here who are trying to
push the idea that this seems to be from
some time ago this is not yeah yeah yeah
that's not from today but it's uh yeah
it's from Jim Jordan and again trying to
push this idea that oh if president
Trump wouldn't sit his fat ass in that
chair he would have pushed the diet coke
button called Putin on the phone sucked
him off and then said hey let me get
Brittany Greiner back
so it's
it's it's just the it's just the right I
mean they they've got to own back what
they've said right you know like the
fact that they're bitching and
complaining about
them thinking
that Trump would be able to avoid a war
would be able to release prisoners right
um well I mean [ __ ] even with just just
the simple fact of gas prices they're
like oh Joe Biden's responsible for gas
prices and then the gas prices go down
they're like oh well it's eight dollars
on some island off the coast of where
the [ __ ] ever because you can't get
gasoline there so that's the problem is
eight dollars there right as as gas goes
down and gas is going to go back up not
because of Biden because of OPEC and we
and we should all understand that but
they don't give a [ __ ] about reality
they don't give a [ __ ] and so the
context to this tweet right here and the
response is coming from a uh Trevor Reed
who is a marine I don't know if anyone
remembers who Trevor Reed was but he was
uh basically detained in Russia in 2019.
so Tony uh correct me who was the
president in 2019
um you know it seems like in 2016 there
was this technicality that that person
won on they didn't win the popular vote
because right no one [ __ ] likes them
and they're a [ __ ] loser but I think
it was um it's this fat slob that lives
down in South Florida right now at a
place called Mar-A-Lago where he's he's
harboring uh documents and committing
crimes I don't know uh His Name Escapes
Me Right Now I want to say like a
grandpa poopy pants or the Cheeto desk
you and all right but so so Trevor was
detained in in Moscow in December 2018
okay he was arrested on espeon's charges
uh which he you know denied right and
Trump was President Trump was the
president at that time you mean the guy
that Jim Jordan's saying right here that
he he would a snap of a finger would
have got Brittany grinder back exactly
yeah okay the guy the guy that Jim
scoring gets down and dirty for
uh uh the sound effects right yeah you
know I mean if anyone we're not going to
talk about [ __ ] too much today I promise
I'm gonna try to lay off some dick talk
Jim Jordan uh you know doesn't like to
report certain things sex friends being
one of them right the main one
um but this is a moment where you know
Jim Jordan wants to [ __ ] project
about how president Trump would have
saved Trevor Reed when Trevor Reed was
detained and kept in Russia during the
time he was president now this now this
account from Trevor Reed here because
it's got a blue check but we know we
can't trust that now but that is a
verified check yeah that is a notable
person that's verified this is not an
eight dollar check right this is before
everyone was talking just making sure
but
he was released in what
2022. wait wait a second wait a second
are you saying are you saying that
the guy who Jim Jordan says would have
snapped his fingers and Putin would have
bound to his wishes and sent Brittany
Greiner immediately on a plane couldn't
negotiate to get Trevor Reed home or
didn't hmm I don't know if he didn't try
or what but Trevor even had something to
tell Jim Jordan here because this is a
real reply he says yeah big thanks to
president Trump for getting myself
involved uh uh Whelan out of Russia not
in other words you're so full of [ __ ]
Jim Jordan listen Trump doesn't give a
[ __ ] about anybody but himself right and
if you [ __ ] haven't learned that yet
I don't know what the hell you're
working on why do why do you think he
didn't give 5 000 Taliban prisoners back
because he cares about the war in
Afghanistan he gave them away for his
own little game it was for him yeah him
and him alone and so he could take
credit and then when his stupid plan
[ __ ] failed he forced the dod and the
military to carry out the stupid
bone-headed plan and when it failed he's
like no not my problem right I mean we
literally have a photo of Mike Pompeo
there being like ah yeah right we're
just shaking hands with this element and
the only reason why Mike Pompeo had to
go over there and negotiate him is
because when Trump's like let's have him
at Camp David everyone's like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about are you why
would you ever bring someone if there
was ever a fear like hey maybe we not
bring terrorist or organization onto
American soil you know the ones that may
have been responsible for I don't know
events like what was it what was that
time it was in 2001 it was in September
yeah yeah 9 11. oh yeah yeah right the
thing the very thing yeah significant
event the insignificant event that
started a 20-year pointless War
between ridiculous yeah dude it's just
so anyway you can't you can't get past
the stupid and it gets dumber and dumber
every day it just keeps getting dumber
and this this take on Brittany Greiner
here's here's how I feel about it this
take that they have on Brittany Greiner
is totally going to [ __ ] be a
liability for them in the 2024 election
even right they can't they will not be
able to stop themselves to two years
from now talking about how it's so
egregious that Joe Biden got Brittany
Greiner home like like what the [ __ ]
yeah they literally also you would keep
that as a talking point yeah no totally
and I mean I would just reverse it on
them and fake Gabe and other people I
thought you guys love guns right I
thought you guys [ __ ] love guns what
happened to the Second Amendment
this is a guy whose arms dealer wouldn't
you guys be so far right yeah I don't
know maybe
the same people who are for uh
[ __ ] himself Putin poopoo Putin
um I could easily see those people being
like yeah great we got the Arms Dealer
back in Russia because we love you know
Rand Paul you got [ __ ] Marjorie
Taylor green you got all these people
who are pro Putin
but you're not are you telling me that
you're not pro Putin getting this guy
back you know like what's it's weird
it's weird [ __ ] let's do this because I
want to show everyone this [ __ ] tweet
that you pointed out um from Donald
Trump Jr it's just absolute vile
[ __ ] that he that of course it's
Donald Trump Jr what else would he
[ __ ] post besides vile garbage so
let's do this let's go to the countdown
let's start the shitless Roundup
start it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the shitlist
he reached the part of the show where we
round up all the Tweety tweets and the
trendy Trends and boy
do we have some
[ __ ] to disinfect today with some
sunlight um you were pointing this out
earlier it's Gabe Sanchez it says Donald
Trump Jr has intentionally forgotten
about his father's ordered the release
of 5 000 Taliban soldiers
can't wait for the next Coke fuel video
featuring the finger puppets
look I am Donald Trump Jr and I
definitely do not do cocaine and I hate
Hunter Biden because his dad loves him
and my dad hates me right it's really
[ __ ] weird I mean
let's not forget this family the Trump
family is pro Putin pro-russia
anti-america
so I mean even if you were to go I mean
like because he's uh he's already made a
video back when the news first broke
about the potential negotiation of a
trade or a swap you mean Junior here
yeah he he went he already had his like
he did a video
do another one I guarantee it oh yeah
and and I'm sure in this video I I don't
have it I'm sure I'm sure we can find it
somewhere but I'm sure in this video
almost positive and I don't I don't
recall it at all but I'm sure he says
how
his father my father could get Brittany
Greiner here in a snap of a finger and
he which you know which is funny because
all the way back in July
uh Trump already sided with Russia he
already he tried to blast the U.S
government saying the attempt to the
attempting to free Brittany Greiner
being imprisoned over this cannabis
possession
uh was something that was let's be clear
though let's be clear this cannabis
right can't do the John Junior cannabis
possession
it is it is literally residue yeah that
she it was it was residue possession of
residue right the [ __ ] out of here with
that again we know we know we know it's
[ __ ] charges we know it's a [ __ ]
incarceration they all know it we know
it Putin knows it and he and and Donald
Trump is trying to spend it in his in
his favor here here here's what he says
in this vile tweet he says you guys know
how to make sure Putin keeps arresting
Americans
um and severely punishing them
trade him an arms dealer AKA The
Merchant of death I can only see him
doing he's gonna he's definitely gonna
do he's gonna do it The Merchant of
death
someone guilty of conspiring to kill
Americans and aiding a terrorist
organization the American hating Jesus
Christ
WNBA activist great trade again
he's like uh we don't want the blade the
gay black female back here in our
country yeah but none of that it's
successful gay black wow I mean in this
country because of course he has America
hating WNBA if she [ __ ] hated America
why would she play for the [ __ ] USA
olympic team why would she want to come
back here right it doesn't make any
sense the idea that oh this person hates
America you can still love the country
and speak out against it like I know our
country [ __ ] is in a weird [ __ ]
timeline right now we have crazy people
Q Anon people we've got this orange
[ __ ] moglodyte trying to or stealing
and still still hiding government
documents we find out yesterday the day
before like this yeah I'm still trying
to drag down that's where there's
supposedly two of them in a storage unit
that broke like right before we got off
the air so yeah that the whole the whole
thing is just insane that we live in the
assignment but again I can still
love being an American or love living in
this country while still voicing
my feedback you know well like it
doesn't it seems like but here's the
thing too because it's the same it's the
same mentality or way of thinking that
they have when it comes to any political
figure you cannot speak out against
Trump or else you are not a Republican
or you're not part of the base or if you
do speak out against Trump then you're a
rhino does that mean I'll never be a
republican I hope that's what that means
because yeah obviously but it's saying
like if you're a republican like never
inviting to the party you've made them I
do not want to identify as a republican
right they say if you go against Trump
or you speak out against Trump not like
in their cult then you are not an
American you're not a republican you're
a right you know all this it's either
like you're not a Republican or you're a
rhinos which is it you know well but
here's the thing though it's it's just
it's it's just all stupidity really oh
yeah even this argument that Donald
Trump Jr is trying to make here where
he's like oh well Putin is intentionally
arresting Americans and jailing them so
so he can get back you know his soldiers
if really that was the case wouldn't he
be trading a [ __ ] ton for Snowden
I mean if that was really the case he's
not
he's not
he's not trading that's not how it's
working yeah the administration could
give a [ __ ] less about Snowden I'm sure
I'm sure Department of Justice would
love to have Snowden back yeah but the
administration does not give a [ __ ]
about Snowden Snowden went there to go
hide
from possible crimes that he committed
Brittany Greiner went there to play
basketball
she happened to have a device that had a
little bit of residue on it when she
walked through the airport
they knew they knew she was gay
in Russia that's one reason why they
[ __ ] love Russian I'm sure fake Gable
confirmed this horse in the chat the
reason why he loves Putin he loves
Russia they [ __ ] hate them some lgbtq
Community yeah you're not going to tell
me that a certain I don't know
government Authority wouldn't already
have files on people coming in
especially people who are of like a
certain caliber of status you tell me
they wouldn't have the whole [ __ ]
background check on you absolutely well
why do you think Matt taivi is doing
what he's doing with Elon Musk right he
lived in Moscow for a while you don't
think there you don't think Putin's Got
dirt on that [ __ ] from when he
lived in Moscow come on you do not go to
Russia and do anything really like yeah
don't don't even sneeze in a cafe
they'll have that [ __ ] on tape
um speaking of stupidity on tape did you
see this [ __ ] video of Sean Hannity
about the Georgia election
s
you can't get any [ __ ] dumber than
him talking about the difference between
votes and ballots I don't even know what
the [ __ ] I don't know if I've seen this
one I've seen the video I've seen the
videos of them being like well I guess
we gotta we gotta do what the Democrats
do we gotta send uh mail in we gotta
send our belts in the mail
they've always done what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you no one told you I mean no
it's not that no one told you you
literally told people not to trust me
right ballots don't do you said go in
person so I'm sorry that maybe the
outcome of an election was determined by
I don't know maybe the weather so people
didn't show up because they were told to
wait until the last day
oh that's on you guys there's literally
back and forth as I now and then that
you can see of them saying don't trust
mail-in ballots they're doing this the
Democrats they're mailing and then this
time to be like oh well why is balance
just Democrats all these fingers being
pointed it's almost like they're telling
them not to vote yeah it's really
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] but here in this clip
he's trying he's trying really hard and
like I'm trying to even understand it a
little bit like a good Freeze Frame
though
is he [ __ ] his pants I don't know
that's the Putin face
um but but I really I can't really
figure out like I watched it a couple
times and my response was it just keeps
getting Dumber because I couldn't
[ __ ] make out what he's trying to say
the difference between a boat and a
ballot he's trying to make it as if
a vote quote is different than a ballot
like okay they are two separate things
like you put your vote on a ballot right
but it is like the I just don't get what
he's trying to I don't understand where
they're going with this anymore I guess
I could see that angle where it's like
oh you put a vote in about but either
way you're when you give your best thing
though a ballot is a balance accounted
it has the votes and the plural on it I
don't [ __ ] just listen it doesn't make a
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] listen it's not that
long and it doesn't take long to get to
the stupidity of course it's Sean
Hannity playing a very different game on
Election Day and the day is leading up
to election day the Republicans are
Democrats are not as interested in the
quality of a candidate or holding
rallies or exciting votes oh my God
kissing babies oh Jesus shaking hands
why do they love kissing babies I don't
know I don't know what their obsession
is with children they're like you gotta
shake it off and kiss babies like I get
that phrase that's a bit Antiquated in
how people uh go out and and campaign
but the fact that you're still talking
about kissing babies it's weird that
like that is that is a bar that they
that they set like look you gotta kiss
some babies to get elected like what the
[ __ ] I mean I get I get retail politics
right I understand that [ __ ] yeah yeah
you know whatever but you [ __ ]
weirdos are always complaining about Joe
Biden standing in a picture with
children and stuff and then you're like
well why isn't why isn't a war not going
out there and intentionally smooching on
babies like Jesus Christ but also they
they said they forced through a
candidate that's not qualified or
whatever he just said a moment ago which
basically was that the idea that that
he's being like oh they're they're going
to push through a cannon that's not it
doesn't have experience is not qualified
says a bunch of random [ __ ] about
vampires and werewolves talks about how
we raise Donald Trump's kids even though
he's 14 years older than done and his
babies
lies about his secret children
to have abortions of course you go even
after they were like no I can't do it
and he goes no you're going to do it
here's a wad of cash gives another one
700 check with the thank you card that
he says
I am not opposed I am not opposed to
those abortions that Herschel Walker
paid for those women one of those
abortions my God I'm Glady people but
even after even after the fact the
second woman came forward and had a
interview with ABC and revealed that not
only
did he say all right get an abortion but
then threatened her to be like the woman
I'm with which I believe was is his
current wife but I'm not sure about that
one exactly uh but I know that she said
well I mean they believe in sanctity of
marriage too right right yeah exactly
like oh all the cheating all the Affairs
great job buddy that's the candidate you
want to support the Kenneth you want to
support is the one that's going to
threaten a woman to say get a [ __ ]
abortion or
your life and the life of your baby is
going to be at risk what kind of weak
pathetic person says that
well a republican but let's listen let's
listen to Sean Hannity here after he's
you know talking about kissing babies
let's listen to what he says about
balancing votes let's see what he's
trying to let's see if he can make sense
of it Ferris no Democrats they're hiding
they're avoiding debates they're
avoiding uh their adoring media fans
they're raising hundreds of millions of
dollars they're using those on negative
ads against Republicans and most
importantly they are playing they're not
playing it let's get a vote game they're
playing a ballot game Democrats are only
interested in getting their hands on
enough ballots that they believe will
put them over the top to win an election
what in the [ __ ] is an election besides
getting more people to put their vote on
a ballot than the other opponent what
the [ __ ] is he dot I can't figure out
like what his angle is I don't even know
but let's address the main accusation he
just said he just said Democratic
candidates were avoiding debates the
only one that I can recall was care Lake
versus Katie Hopps Katie hops was like
I'm not going to give you the [ __ ]
time to spew your crazy conspiracy
theories because we've already seen you
do it during the primary debates with
your other Republican candidates and the
other people you're against no one else
no no one else said no and she beat
Carrie leak she banned Carrie like not
showing up exactly which which a lot of
people at the time in the moment said
you're you're making a mistake and it
wasn't quite the mistake everyone
thought it was but what about what about
in Georgia specifically the race yeah
that that that Sean Walker is talking
about here Herschel Walker never showed
up to a single goddamn debate wow he
showed up to the one where yeah until it
was the final more or less debate before
the uh the general election he showed up
to that one pulled out the fake badge as
a prop got [ __ ] owned people laughed
at him right before and they would kept
pulling it out after yeah I've done work
with police okay that's
the idea that Sean Hannity wants to say
oh no no no Democratic candidate was
willing to debate only one person denied
debating a [ __ ] loony bin the rest of
the people said yeah let's [ __ ]
debate let's have a debate other people
if you notice there was a trend every
single Republican candidate that went up
typically did and there though
especially the Trump the trump-backed
candidates their strategy was do one
debate don't do it again and I believe
that strategy was put yourself out there
maybe you can hold your own 100 of the
time you [ __ ] goofed on yourself
but I think they were hoping that by the
time the second debate rolled around and
then the general election that by the
second debate of like I'm not going to
do a second debate and then when the
general election comes around I think
they were hoping like okay that was at
least a coupled a few weeks ago nobody's
gonna remember the dumb [ __ ] that I said
and ever you had um
who do you have you had uh
uh Herschel Walker you had Dr Oz did
that who is another one
um
you mean that didn't show up they showed
up once they did one debate and then
they were out well I'm I mean Marco
Rubio that was another one Marco Rubio
showed up to one and then bounced all of
these people did one debate thinking
okay I'll show myself God owned wow but
that was that was just to say I did
debate no no exactly that's what I'm
saying they all did it to be like I did
just to say but then after that they're
like I'm not gonna do it again because I
know that I'm gonna get owned again and
it's close future it's a whole
future-proofing thing that you were
talking about exactly but also I think I
think in their mind they're like it's
it's uh
uh long enough before the actual
election that somebody will just forget
there's a bunch of other stuff that's in
the news cycle yeah and then mastriano
wouldn't debate Shapiro like all of
these people Adriana wouldn't let the
press in his [ __ ] official events
yeah because he was saying some gross
vile [ __ ] that he didn't want the press
to report about yeah um but here's the
thing
is we just watched Sean Hannity talk
about more Democrats are trying to do
same day and blah blah ballots votes
they're you don't vote on a ballot you
ballot on a vote or I don't know what
the hell the less ballots that have
votes should be the winner I mean they
really think this electoral college
thing is all the way down to the county
liver or some [ __ ] but here is Grandpa
Poopypants now this is going to be
really hard to to hear and the reason
why is because it's on recorded from a
cell phone
um now I don't know if you can see this
very clear but in the middle here
there's the there's the the keto dust q
and honor there and then forehead and
then over here is the uh um it looks
like a really big plate with a small
face wearing a tuxedo oh that's what it
looks like to me yeah yeah yeah it looks
like to me and maybe maybe Charlie Kirk
is this oh okay yes yeah yeah dolphin
dolphin fetus now because Charlie Kirk's
standing here at Mar-A-Lago of course
Grandpa Poopypants is gonna try to
regurgitate what Charlie Kirk just tried
to tell him about the Arizona race this
is it's really funny like I actually
find this amusing When Donald Trump is
someone has fed him a new lie right and
he's trying it out right he's trying out
this new life he's like he's you know he
thinks he's like a stand-up comedian
doing like he's doing smaller sets to
try out jokes before he does the bigger
tour right well yeah yeah
trying it out and he can
he can't exactly and he's not really
sure timing the punch line right one you
can tell because he
he really when he's trying something out
he's trying out the [ __ ] hand
gestures he's trying out the tempo The
Voice he's doing a lot of things that
make it [ __ ] ridiculous and hilarious
but you can tell in this moment that
Charlie Kirk off stage at some point has
told Donald Trump what he's about to say
and Donald Trump is going to take credit
for it because that's what he does he
[ __ ] Steals and robs right like he
would be he would be the one he would be
the comedian you're sitting in a in a
bar or in a comedy club and you're
talking to your comedian friends and
you're trying some jokes out on them
right and then they go up before you and
before they go up and when they go up
they they say what the [ __ ] you were
trying to tell them like what the [ __ ]
that's that's what I believe is
happening here oh yeah 100 again it's
hard to hear but just see if you can
make it out
four or five miles long you know because
you understand for hours
even the crowd is laughing he says they
have like three or four miles long what
what Donald Trump is claiming here right
what Donald Trump is claiming here is is
that there were there I can't I can't
even I can't I can't it's [ __ ] weird
he is saying that there were people
standing in line in Arizona for five
months does he know what a mile is
I I wanna okay here I'm gonna give you a
a video okay for context
um this is a this is
okay this is from two months ago okay
this is for Queen Elizabeth II her her
death right
okay this is this is what an actual five
mile long
line of people mourning looks like
oh my God uh here at the Tony Michaels
podcast we bring receipts
um and I mean when I say receipts we
bring them here is the um do I need I
don't need to play the sound for this
doing no I don't think so it's just like
them talking so you're fine so this is
this okay so this is this is that was a
zigzag Line This was a line look this is
not now now now a little bit of context
here okay because these people aren't
voting they're just walking past an area
to view something so it's not like they
have to get right to get there they
don't have to spend you know 10 20
minutes whatever you need to make sure
that you have the right people checked
on them this is what five miles long of
people in line looks like and like Tony
said these are people that are just like
looking and be like oh yep there's the
there's the casket oh there she is
because you can see him just walking
past they're not even boom I'm really
allowed to stop through that's all they
do that's down the bridge past Big Ben
past the Thames River River [ __ ]
zigzag through that's five miles I don't
even know if there's just like the idea
that oh here let me let me see if I can
figure out how many people fit in five
miles yeah yeah see if if so if people
were standing line and you know
reasonably speaking here how how many
people would be standing in a five mile
line now again this is this is where
Charlie Kirk right I believe Charlie
Kirk or someone has had a conversation
with him the Cheeto dusk you and honor
yeah and they have exaggerated
that this Maya that this this line was
miles long like oh my god there were
there were just my there was lines that
were five miles long of course you know
you would exaggerate that right like
yeah oh the line was all the way out the
building but they would you would say if
you really wanted it to sound like a
really really long line you would say
five miles
you're not serious you're you're not
being literal so let's look at I'm sure
I'm just I'm gonna do some some simple
math here now in
in Cincinnati yeah in 2016 okay there
was 4 000 people in a half mile voting
line whoosh so you're telling me in two
and a half miles four thousand people
were standing in line yeah which by the
way
that's not good it's not a good Mark for
democracy but 4 000 people in a half
mile line now half mile and then you
multiply that by 10 because that's half
times 10 guys math is five now ten
that's ten times four thousand is forty
thousand people is what they're saying
assuming just off this math here four
thousand one one location that's one
location one location that's not
Statewide
right that's not Statewide so they're
saying that there were 40 000 people
using this kind of back of that napkin
math here 40 000 people in line
for hours for hours I mean if if there
was a line that had 40 000 people and it
would take a while to work your way
through that line just to give people
context 40 000 people is like uh who how
many students are at like University of
Illinois University of Ohio University
see if you can look this up see if you
can find what the the highest tally was
for a voting location in Arizona you
know what I mean like a single location
how many people voted at that location
I'm sure that number exists somewhere
yeah I don't know if it exists yet but
I'm sure it will exist in the data
somewhere eventually yeah well you know
what I mean like they haven't sorted out
that [ __ ] yet but there's got to be
there's got to be a number that shows
how many people
you know the highest the highest uh
location that was voted at the most I'm
sure it's not even [ __ ] close to 40
000. that's a lot of [ __ ]
that's a lot of people in one area and I
doubt in one room because you also have
to assume that based on it you know
based on certain populations some of
them are super small and they fit maybe
a couple thousand people Max because the
voting locations right but that's just
like well that that was one of the
reasons why the NFL uh and the NBA as
well they were so willing to lend their
stadiums right um during the 2020
election because they knew it the the
turnout it they felt the turnout was
going to swell and they needed a big
location that was designed to house
thousands of people right to make sure
that people had the opportunity to vote
and I think the Staples Center then the
Staple Center
um weren't they a voting location I
believe
um there were several of them that were
oh though in LA
well all around the country there were
several NBA
um stadiums and football stadiums again
again the reason why is because those
buildings and those complexes are
designed
to move people right thousands of people
to move them quickly like that that's
the design of the [ __ ] building all
right so
I can't give you 2022 results yeah well
I mean but if I go to 2020 results yeah
so which the turnout was higher in
Arizona in 2020 than 2022 right I mean
it's close but so if I were to go for
like the Gen you know a presidential
general election in November 3rd 2020
total ballots cast
Apache was thirty five thousand seven
hundred seventy six
uh
uh one County that's one County that's
not a precede that's not a location
that's not a location but these are
these are not going to give me locations
these are just going to give me the
people that were voted for in the total
so I don't know oh here we go here we go
this will give you a better idea
so in Apache County there's 44 precincts
okay okay so 44. 35
000. now if you want to go to Maricopa
County yeah you've got which is the
largest county so you've got the highest
populated two million eighty nine
thousand five hundred sixty three that
was Maricopa but Maricopa also has 743
precincts yeah
um but that doesn't tell me because in a
Precinct like you're gonna have well
right they're gonna be they're probably
and especially in Arizona they're
probably going to be lopsided right
you're gonna have three scenes to just
have uh in in in areas where they don't
want people to vote black neighborhoods
um they're gonna have they're going to
have
um
poll you know they're gonna have a high
turnout in one Precinct right whereas in
other neighborhoods if we if we take
this number like 2 million again we're
just doing Simple Math here like I
obviously we don't know how it all Lays
out so I'm just going to take the
average if we were to say Maricopa
County in the
two thousand uh the 2020 election just
for ballots that were cast so you have
two million these are actually people
that walked in and cast their vote on a
ballot not to confuse Sean Hannity these
are the balls that were cast so just shy
of 2.1 million and there's 743 precincts
if we do the math on that
that would be
an average of 2800 whoa ballots no yes
you have to mean 28 000 games no I'm
sorry there's got to be another zero
there the math look the math doesn't lie
so these lines so these lines were not
five miles long is what you're saying
there's no we're not if if assuming the
other math on Cincinnati four thousand
and a half mile that's 40 000 people in
line for hours on end and if we take the
2020 election as our kind of uh Baseline
our Benchmark we look at that and we say
okay in Maricopa County which is the one
they always [ __ ] and moan about with
the most amount of people's over 2
million almost 2.1 but there's 743
precincts we take a running average on
that or just we just take a simple
average on that that's
2812 votes or 0.33 if you want the
[ __ ] third seems really close to a
Five Mile Line to me yeah just very
close which is again that's like a
quarter mile line right here's the thing
here's the thing is
literally
anyone who's ever walked driven anything
any kind of measurement inside of a mile
would understand that there were not
there were not miles 40 000 people is
how many people you would go to [ __ ]
Beyonce concert like that's how many
like that's a stadium is there a Five
Mile Line outside the stadium no no
there's not and because there's other
entrances which means there would be
other locations to vote you know it's
kind of the same okay let's go but let's
go back because it it just it doesn't
get any smarter it gets Dumber okay
imagine imagine it getting dumber than
believing that a line is five miles long
to vote in a Precinct in Arizona but
let's listen
[Music]
and thousands and thousands of people
left that line
they had to go home hold their sons
literally again they had to go see their
doctor they were older or maybe not just
as if as if anyone voting has like
Democrats have nothing to do on voting
day like like it is a national holiday
for Democrats it's not for republicans
and Democrats get off on work their kids
they do not have to worry about kids or
school
schedule soccer games they do not
schedule concerts they do not schedule
anything doctors appointments or
anything on these days because they're
Democrats like it's a total coordinated
effort to make sure the Democrats have
nothing to do but stand in Five Mile
lines to vote and if that's the logic
though but if that's the logic game
Sanchez that means that everyone's
standing in the [ __ ] line was a
Democrat they literally don't even
[ __ ] understand what they're saying
while they're saying it and and of
course he doesn't because he's [ __ ]
Trump but did you notice like his
inflection and like it's almost defined
where error right it's almost like he's
doing an impersonation of himself doing
I think impersonation of himself
I think he's kind of he's testing out
new material it is I just figure out how
because 2016 Trump didn't work in 2020
and it definitely didn't work for the
2022 midterms in terms of backing these
candidates so I think right now he's
trying out a new persona maybe where
he's like oh if I try this or do this
then that will appeal to bet people
better not my policies not my [ __ ]
bigoted views but if I can create a new
character then this will totally work I
mean this is
it's it's [ __ ] insane it it just gets
dumber and dumber and dumber and they
don't have any other direction but to
get dumber and and I keep going back to
because he's talking about Arizona and
Kerry Lake because we've said this many
times and this was my belief weeks and
weeks before the election that Arizona
is the one they wanted and the reason
why is because of Carrie Lee because she
was willing to do the most election
denying of any other candidate that he
had endorsed and and it's only uh you
know now we know that that's the truth
because that's all they're doing right
that's all they're doing is denying
election she's like living down at
Mar-A-Lago just to [ __ ] deny
elections it's weird [ __ ] but the thing
is the the the people of Arizona
listen for months of Kerry Lake talking
Katie Hobbs was almost silent she was
almost silent I actually believe that
Katie Ops was not a good candidate she
was not a good candidate she was a
horrible candidate I hope I hope she
makes a decent Governor because if she
is the same as she as a governor she was
a candidate Arizona is gonna suck but
not but Arizona's like but not as bad of
if Carrie Lake was the [ __ ] governor
for crying out loud I mean it's it's
astonishing to me that they they lost an
election because they ran a candidate
who was like [ __ ] you We're Not Gonna
Let You We're not gonna believe you when
you vote and we're not gonna let you
decide our elections we we who are in
the election are going to decide who
wins and it's us who wins no matter what
you say in Arizona's like no you're
[ __ ] crazy we'll vote for the other
person who who gives a [ __ ] who it is
yeah and then as soon as soon as the
election certified they just prove why
arizonans did what they did which was
vote for the other person because you
people are [ __ ] nuts yeah I mean
especially I don't think you know you
you see a candidate who spews
conspiracies tells them the day of I'm
going to be your the press's worst
nightmare like you're not setting
yourself up for Success especially when
you're when you're completely dependent
on this idea that the 2020 election was
rigged and despite the fact that we've
seen again and again and again and again
that there was no widespread voter fraud
the most amount of concentrated fraud we
saw was in the [ __ ] Villages Florida
all Republicans and that we see during
the Jan 6 investigation we see uh during
the uh the smartmatic and the Dominion
software uh lawsuits for billions of
dollars against Mike Lindell Fox News
oan News Max Rudy Giuliani like all of
these people did not have actual
evidence to say oh there was fraud Rudy
Giuliani waved around a bunch of papers
he said I have all these affidavits as
his [ __ ] hair leaked down the side of
his face hey he farted on some people
okay yes
we know that but the idea that's an
accomplishment in and of it it was crazy
like people are still studying that
event right now they're like we didn't
know it could be passed through [ __ ]
flatulence but we did you know it
happens well you know speaking of
craziness and believing crazies and
crazy statements you remember
um Infowars last week Kanye West was on
there
you remember that yeah that was quite a
that was a trip yeah yeah right
um I think we did a few minutes on it
here we may have breezed over it but no
I apparently um Nick Fuentes was with
Kanye West on on the show and when when
Kanye West was like I love Hitler and I
I you know Hitler's the greatest version
ever Nick Fuentes is shaking he said yes
yes yes yes well apparently Alex Jones
is now they're kind of feuding with uh
Nick Fuentes they want to debate because
even Alex Jones if Alex Jones is like
you're gross and vile dude you got
problems have you did you see it did you
see the response that prompted this
response
um well I'm gonna show this is um this
is Nick Fuentes in a Twitter space I
don't know if Elon Musk that knows that
there's Nazis in Twitter spaces oh yeah
but there are not yeah he's a Nazi right
but this is this is Nick Fuentes again
it's an audio because it is a Twitter
space yeah if no one knows what Twitter
space is up is out there it's kind of
like
um like a group Zoom meeting but only
audio Yeah right it's only audio so you
have a host of the of the of the space
and sometimes a co-host and then they
allow people to speak and someone what
Nick Fuentes speak now how did he let
him because Nick Fuentes doesn't have
his Twitter account back right no that
would mean that he he like assuming that
Nick Fuentes was IP band right right
like
in in other words in other words he
couldn't create sock accounts yeah from
wherever his home I like assuming it was
his home IP address then he couldn't do
it like from his cell phone yeah yeah
but let's say he made a sock account at
another location that's I don't know
maybe the headquarters for yay 24. then
he could totally sound salacious yeah
well so he's on a Twitter space here and
um well let's just listen and then and
then we'll go back to the quotes
we're not laughing
and it's really hard to hear right I
apologize because it is a Twitter space
and he's sitting way away from the
microphone I got this [ __ ] all
the way up and you can barely hear
that's why I say we're going to go back
and listen to the quotes but I want to
play it for fake game to make sure he
knows that I'm not just bullshitting
this is a real thing
okay there he says Hitler was epic in a
lot of ways epic is the word that he
uses of course of course Kanye used the
word love
uh Hitler I think it was that long I'm
not sure exactly how yeah he he said uh
yeah
[Music]
yeah right right okay let's let's let's
finish here he's only got a few more
seconds to to
um you know
um sent for Hitler here Nick Fuentes
that is let's listen
okay
[Music]
and uh
non-negotiable not not just because we
like the Hugo Boss uniform okay we
really love them
and we love all the Nazis today they
love Hitler and they love all the Nazis
too Gabe's engines that's what Nick
Fuentes says we love Hitler and we
really love all all
the Nazis too
you know I've been saying this
and I guess I gotta say it again
if there is a Nazi sitting at a table
eating
and there's 10 other people sitting
there eating with that Nazi having a
good old time talking about Nazi things
yeah
you have 11 Nazis at the table okay that
is what you have now
I believe this is why Alex Jones because
even even the CR the crazy that the
demons have not taken Alex Jones in a
place where he can support a Hitler
loving Nazi he literally the craziness
that Alex Jones has and the absolute I
mean this guy believes in [ __ ]
Chemtrails and [ __ ] lizard people all
kinds of crazy ass [ __ ] but he is not
willing and and Alex Jones doesn't
believe that [ __ ] that's all man but he
is not willing to go out on a limb
as far as Kanye and Nick Fuentes here so
much yeah there's a for the most amount
of uh for the I guess for most of
humanity I would say uh
there's there's a there's like what you
would call an absolute truth right and
then absolute truth would say hey uh
Hitler did some very very bad disgusting
stuff right he uh committed genocide he
was the the manufacturer of the
Holocaust he did uh kill six million
Jewish people and it's well documented
well documented now you got people who
are like oh well if there were you know
I've I've heard him talk about the
Holocaust in regards to or as an analogy
talk about cooking cookies in the oven
uh which was disgusting
um and you you look at people like him
and then you look at people like Alex
Jones and Gavin McGinnis the the [ __ ]
founder of The Proud boys yeah we showed
that yesterday or was that the day
before I don't know I think the day
before yeah I don't know it all runs
together right but you look you look at
this scenario and you're like when you
have two people like Alex Jones and
Gavin McGinnis say
ah Hitler did some bad stuff man
um he killed these people like don't say
it to a microphone that he's epic do not
say that into a microphone and so you
have this moment where these crazy
conspiracy theory racists are being like
Hitler was a bad guy let's not that's
actually on the whole Hitler's cool
thing right and so when you look at that
you're like oh you know you [ __ ] up
because yeah but the thing is Gabe
Sanchez we have
for months and months and months said on
this show that Nick Fuentes is pushing
the Republican narrative he has been
pushing this Republican narrative with
proud boys Oath Keepers Patriot front
Charlottesville I mean this is the
[ __ ] alt-right it is what drives the
Republican party there is no question
and I'll give you proof this morning
on the house floor
when you're talking about marriage
equality and codifying marriage equality
in this country
this is a representative representative
good is his name he is not good he is he
is a vile piece of [ __ ] his name does
not describe him at all yeah
but this is his little diatribe that he
puts into the official record on the
house floor about marriage equality and
the lgbtq community and you'll wonder
where he gets it from
it's Nick Fuentes in the alt-right and
the America First Nazis because he is
one representative good is a [ __ ]
Nazi I don't care what you say when and
you're gonna see what he says about
bestiality here which really honestly
Nazis had the most punchable face oh and
this really this gives you more cause to
believe that but listen to this vile
garbage that there's this they're saying
this [ __ ] on our house floor
our house floor they're saying this in
the microphones on our record in 2022.
listen to this honestly the bill should
be called the disrespect for Marriage
Act this bill certainly disrespects
God's definition of marriage a
definition that has served his creation
well for more than five thousand years
of recorded history and his definition
is the only one that really matters this
bill would codify into federal law the
Supreme Court's wrongly decided oberfeld
decision and ensure that the marriage
laws in the most liberal State
irrespective of how radical they might
become in the future think polygamy
bestiality child marriage or whatever
must be legally recognized in all states
or whatever he says polygamy bestiality
and and what else did he say I don't
know and whatever yeah the the point
that he's trying to make with the
bestiality because that's the one that
he's pinpointing there and whatever the
reason why is because he is saying that
lgbtq the community
not only does not have the right to
marry we do not have to consider them
humans that is what he oh he said child
as if as if Democrats are running around
in Tennessee trying to marry [ __ ]
children and pass laws on it get the
[ __ ] out of here then nonsense but this
is Bob good of Virginia
and this this this vile piece of trash
has the [ __ ] has the [ __ ] audacity
to invoke God on the floor of Our House
of Representatives and then dehumanize
an entire Community because of who they
love
and the their Liberty to love who they
want to love because Bob good does not
give a flying [ __ ] about marriage I can
almost guarantee it and it's not about
the lgbtq community marrying he he does
not want them to exist is what he's
saying that's what the [ __ ] he's saying
he is a God damn Nazi and Until you
realize that the same language that Nick
Fuentes has been has been putting in
place for the last several years
since Charlottesville which Bob good is
the representative of Charlottesville by
the way which is you know almost almost
[ __ ] ironic
that Nick Fuentes is pushing this
narrative Nick Fuentes saying same the
same [ __ ] same [ __ ] that is spewing out
of Bob Good's mouth right here on the
house floor Nick Fuentes his words his
commentary his beliefs and his his Nazi
little fantasies are playing out on our
house floor today when it comes to the
marriage equality Act
and these [ __ ] vile Nazi Republicans
saying this [ __ ] on the floor let's
finish
to hear what the hitler-loving Bob good
says and he is Hitler loving because I'm
sure he's got a special place in his
heart for Mr Fuentes it was wrong when
the Supreme Court made law and the
overfeld decision requiring that the
marriage law in Massachusetts had to
become the law of the whole country when
Massachusetts approved gay marriage this
was overriding the will of the people
and their elected representatives as no
other state to that point had been able
to pass through referendum or state
legislature a gay marriage law the fact
is traditional biblical marriage is the
foundation of a strong society and a
strong culture I'll say it once again
almost everything that plagues our
society is a failure to follow God's
design for marriage morality and the
family the perfect omniscient immutable
God knows what he's doing but this
legislation repeals the correct
definition of marriage and federal code
and requires the federal government to
recognize any marriage if the marriage
was vowed in the state where it was
performed
hey Bob good you can take your God and
you can shove it straight up your
[ __ ] ass God ain't got nothing to do
with our government or our democracy you
have the right to believe it you have
the right to [ __ ] hold those beliefs
but you do not have the right to oppress
your [ __ ] God on other [ __ ] people
so you can take that religion you got
and you're talking about and stick it
where it [ __ ] belongs that's all I
got to say to Bob good
um now there's a couple other Clips I
want to show here of the house floor
what what but what is this clip you sent
me here
you're on mute you're on mute
uh what what we'll do is play the clip
from the house floor and then we'll
bring it back because it's tied to Nick
Fuentes oh okay I get you I get you got
you okay so and it's also about punch
and hit I mean punching Nazis oh okay
that sounds great sounds like a great
clip uh let's let me go to the one of
Victory heartsler because I was talking
about this one earlier
um where she is literally sobbing and
begging her her colleagues in the house
to vote against equality she says these
[ __ ] words let's listen uh let's
bring that there Okay let's listen
Mr Speaker I'll tell you my priority
protect religious liberty protect people
of faith and protect Americans who
believe in the true meaning of marriage
I hope and pray
that my colleagues
will find the courage
to join me
in opposing
this misguided and this dangerous bill
hi yoga
gentlemen
what is the [ __ ] up what in the actual
[ __ ] is that about you can take those
white women tears and go [ __ ] yourself
dangerous again this goes back hey do
you want to know the language of Nick
Fuentes
do you want to know the language of the
Nazis that someone loving someone even
though they have the same genitalia
somehow dangerous you people are out of
your [ __ ] minds you're out of your
[ __ ] minds it's just you're like
you're [ __ ] nuts the the crying the
crying I'm like okay first off you sound
like a [ __ ] crying sound effect it
doesn't even sound real
she think it was fake I mean look maybe
she actually believes that or maybe she
was kind of pulling a uh a [ __ ] Kyle
Rittenhouse he was like
like
she was doing right there and the idea
also
that she's like the translation of what
she said was
I am very upset
that I cannot push my bigoted religious
beliefs onto other people who do not
follow the same religion as me
which is funny considering the fact that
the government you know there's a
separation of church and state right
this idea that we're supposed to be
different that we're supposed to not
bring religion in you've got [ __ ]
Marjorie Taylor green who at one point
was like oh they wanted to swear in on
the Quran oh no no no it's got to be a
Bible and who is that one guy last year
who was like they swore in on something
that wasn't a Bible and then they got
fact checked and they're like they don't
have to be they could [ __ ] swear in a
piece of paper if they won it's whatever
they choose a strap-on dildo if they
want right they do not and does not
happen but Republicans do not they do
not know the actual rules or policies
well even if they do no they do not want
to acknowledge exactly because it
doesn't fit their narrative
um Here's the final vote on the marriage
equality act in the house of course we
know it was going to pass
um because at this point Democrats still
hold the house and we know that they can
get 219 which we only need 218. and if
you look here the Democratic votes are
yay 219 no nay no present no no votes
okay 39 Republicans voted
for the marriage equality act and I I
think that is significant and I'll tell
you why here in a minute yeah but the
Nays are 169. now a lot of people be
like oh well the Nays are worse but you
want to know what's worse
someone voting present on this you weak
[ __ ] I want to know I'm here I
want to know who the person is who voted
present on this on this [ __ ] on this
final vote and then of course there's
four no votes
which in the house is kind of
significant and the reason why it's
significant in the house for a no vote
is because you can vote by proxy in the
house you cannot vote by proxy in the
Senate right you can only vote by
practicing house meaning another house
member can come to the floor and use
their voice to submit your vote to the
record it's all vote by proxy means and
again in the house you can do that you
cannot in the Senate
um but the present vote is the one I
want to know but here's here's out one
258 to 169. uh as yay nay and then of
course one president vote for no votes
but it is and here's the reason why the
39 Republicans is so important to me
because the Republicans are about to
take over the majority in the house
but they they couldn't even make sure
that 39 of these [ __ ] voted
against this because you know they
wanted they did not want these 39 votes
no to be for marriage equality now again
I don't know who the 39 are and I you
know I guess we could smoke that out and
go line by line each representatives and
why it's important in their districts
with their constituency for them to win
in 2020 for you know you could do all
that [ __ ] yeah you could smoke out all
that [ __ ]
but the fact remains
that when when we go into next year in
the next Congress and the next House of
Representatives these Republicans aren't
going to be able to do [ __ ] they're not
going to be able to get [ __ ] done not a
[ __ ] thing I bet they don't even get
the [ __ ] committee off the ground they
can't they probably won't even get it up
is what I'm saying
that's all I'm saying
um [ __ ] it I'm looking it up right now
you want to know who voted uh presence
who was it
all right the person present was a
republican yeah of course Burgess Owens
yeah uh Utah fourth district
Hometown Salt Lake City coward he took
out he took his oath in January 3rd 2021
so it looks like it's his first term
yeah right so now let's look at who
voted
uh no voting yeah the other four cowards
oh but it couldn't even be a good bigot
and vote against this right you want to
know we got Kevin Brady of Texas okay
we've got
uh adding Adam kinzinger oh [ __ ] you
know hey everyone always wants to
[ __ ] say why is Tony so when he
voices against Adam ginzinger that's why
right there he's a [ __ ] coward and
kinsinger just just the bar of saying
hey you need to you need to [ __ ] say
when elections are won they're won
that's not a very high [ __ ] bar I
don't care who says Lee zeldin that's
not surprising no you don't you know you
know what Holland's worth those are the
four hollandsworth who's Holland
Hollingsworth hollandsworth is
Republican on Indiana he's uh okay so so
the so the five the five votes another
crazy person too so present and the four
no votes they're all men they're all
white men
right they're all straight white men
yeah yep
I mean you know they that's how they
identify it's right right
um let's see who let's see how did I'm
gonna assume [ __ ] bobert
there's no way both yeah she was a name
she was an a yeah
no I I mean I mean you could again we
could go through the 39 but the most
significant part about the 39 vote to me
is that at least there's 39 Republicans
that don't want to appear to be so
[ __ ] bigoted
um or they might believe that there
should be marriage equality there
there's probably one probably none that
believe that but at least 39 of them are
willing to pretend but that's
significant going into next year of what
will and what what won't happen and the
reason why it's important is because
folks Republicans are going to prove
next year within a matter of [ __ ]
weeks that they have no idea how to
govern they have not got a [ __ ]
clue and they don't know how to do it
and they won't know how to do it and
they definitely won't do it that's why
they're going to be screaming about a
laptop because they have no [ __ ] glue
head again and it's you know
but also like the other one the other
one that I I don't know many people that
talked about this but do you know the
bill that was up uh uh for the
the
voting and passing the protect our
children act you know that one there was
one no vote there was one no vote who
was the no vote that one uh was it was
McClintock
out of California everyone wanted it to
be Gates I know I know I'm surprised it
wasn't he was probably you know although
you know though it's really it's really
telling that when there's one no vote
for for a bill like that yeah that
you're every everyone's mind goes to and
it's probably the [ __ ] you want to
know rapey gay you want to know other
I'm now I'm looking at now I'm on
mcclintock's page so he voted no against
respect for Marriage Act yeah he voted
uh does he just vote no on everything no
on the patents for Humanity act I don't
know that one he voted no on the child
protection act he voted no on the rule
opioid Abuse Prevention Act of course he
did why wouldn't he I mean this
McClintock seems like a real vile piece
of [ __ ] I bet he's a republican yeah I
know he is but he's out of California so
you know well well hey a California
Republican is a California Republican my
friend I mean okay so here I want to
show you things are crazy like all these
things are crazy good acts that should
have been passed or sorry that should
have been voted yes on you know the
veteran service recognition act but
isn't that but isn't that the America
First Nazi way here is here's the moment
here's the moment
um where Nancy Pelosi and reads the
votes
on this boat the yays are 258 the Nays
are 169 present one
[Laughter]
the motion is okay
I told you I have not seen this clip I
promise you I have not seen this clip
but again the actual the actual Act of
voting present on a bill like this is
[ __ ] laughable that's why I pointed
it out because and I wanted to know who
it was because it is [ __ ] laughable
that you would take a present vote on a
bill like this this is not a hard Bill
to vote on even if you're a [ __ ]
bigot this is not a hard Bill to vote
really honestly the biggest probably
have an easier time to vote against this
than than people who would actually go
through the bill and go hey is this
actually going to do what we wanted to
do is it going to codify it the way that
we want to codify it is it going to make
sure to protect people's Liberty are we
just doing something here as image not
as actual protecting Liberty like that
would be you know questions that someone
who wants to make sure to protect
people's Liberty but vote but he votes
[ __ ] prison and again the entire here
I'll go back
the Nays are 169 present one
she's like motion all right
the idea also that you would be like oh
you know what I'm not gonna actually
voice my opinion here right and get my
vote like if you didn't want it then
vote no right like be a [ __ ] man and
say no grab your [ __ ] balls well but
here's there here's the reason why he
wants to do this Gabe did you know Salt
Lake City is is considered the gayest
city in the United States did you know
that I did not know that look it up look
it up a lot of people say San Francisco
but there has been you know research
done
and San Francisco normally comes in in
second or third but Utah is Salt Lake
City is at the top it's surprising now
because it's no it's why I I'm telling
you I've seen where do you find I can't
find this Google it I'm Googling yeah
San Francisco Washington uh Seattle
Washington okay New York City maybe
maybe I'm wrong but I've heard this
before I've heard this before San
Francisco was definitely got it he's
like look it's it's gay
that's why people love it really but
here's the point okay gayest cities in
America 22. I'm fact checking you San
Francisco California Santa Rosa
California Seattle Washington Boston
Massachusetts Portland Oregon Miami
Florida Albuquerque New Mexico San Diego
California New York City New York
Portland Maine where the [ __ ] are you
getting Utah so I'm telling you I'm
telling you he is future proofing like
you said
he is future proofing unless you unless
you have like an underground scoop on
some some new new lists that are coming
out I don't know just type Salt Lake
City
Utah all right gayest City
you find it it was an article years ago
that I read and I've gone off that that
article ever since okay okay what is
this I think you find it I think I fact
checked me then [ __ ] okay okay
okay okay
you find a survey I want to find what
year this is from
it doesn't tell me anyway all right so
in this article it says the Utah life
Utah life elevated it's like some well I
think Utah's capital is one of the 10
gayest cities in the country according
to a Gallup poll let me go to the Gallup
poll now all right this is from 2015.
yeah that's right yeah yeah 2015. but in
that list
it was San Francisco like the Bay Area
Portland Austin Salt Lake City at the
time was one two three four five six
seven
no longer on that list according it is
in Utah and it's it is on in Utah and it
is in the top 10 so it makes it like the
the again I hope I hope they have a lot
of pride in in Salt Lake City I hope
they have a lot of Pride I said it's
great I I was I went to Salt Lake City I
went to Sundance in Salt Lake City in
2017. okay
I hope they have a lot of Pride and a
lot of allies in Salt Lake City and I
would imagine that's why this weak piece
of [ __ ] took this vote is because he's
future proofing that he didn't vote
against it and he didn't vote for it you
see how that works that's why that's why
on it on a bill like this when she says
present like that and there was one and
there the entire room's like oh my God
Jesus Christ you weak piece of [ __ ]
because everyone knows what you're doing
you're just doing like you said you're
future proofing not just not just for
the for the lgbtq community but for the
people you want to vote yeah you're like
well I didn't say yes and I didn't say
no right I I did not vote against what
like when you're standing in a room full
of people who have a lot of Pride and
who are allies or the lgbtq community he
can say I did not vote against
and then when he goes across town and
he's standing in a room full of a bunch
of bigots he can say I definitely did
not vote for the marriage equality act
right he can do both that's why that's
also one of those things where it's like
okay you you did a no vote why would you
like it's I mean you can you can easily
say no it's not a no vote no no no I'm
what I'm saying is you can say like as a
candidate I voted I was I voted see a no
vote you a no vote you can't say you
voted because you did not vote
right the president votes a [ __ ] joke
but the point is is that that's what
it's for they put it in place to intend
to do that I voted I voted
when we voted for the marriage equality
act and I voted against it
I did not vote for It Whatever whatever
language they want to use it's future
proofing this idea and my guess is is
that he's seen the 2015 Gallup poll I'm
just saying yeah man very well if
somebody uh who's saying what Cebu says
pornhub's releases the searches by
cities is amazing I think they showed
that when the RNC came to town all the
gay porn searches went up and then came
to Salt Lake City is that what you're
saying I think yeah Cebu are you talking
about Salt Lake City do they come to
Salt Lake City and and then they release
those things
that's very interesting I bet you could
tell a lot of [ __ ] from PornHub search
um data like a lot of yeah about about
it there's a ton of stuff they're like
oh no just any any town all towns oh so
any so so any City that the RNC goes
dude that surgeon gay porn goes way up
he goes away and there's nothing wrong
with it I mean if people like [ __ ] gay
porn whatever you know like gay porn I I
I mean I watched a video I watched a
video of these let me you know what let
me do not send me we can't show that on
YouTube
I'm gonna send you a link real quick for
another video I got you
um this is not this is we can't I mean
I'm not again I'm not against gay porn
whatever you want to do whatever floats
your boob but I can't show it on YouTube
Gabe Sanchez no that's not what I'm
saying although although we did one time
uh inadvertently and I shouldn't say
this out loud on the YouTube channel
some of my report it or go find it
remember when we uh Nick Fuentes
um oh yeah you got busted yeah and I was
trying to show the Tweet but I was
trying to hide the the wenis in the
Tweet yeah because he was he was showing
I think he was uh it was an accidental
screenshot or something uh and it showed
that he was searching
um transgender porn or something he was
doing a little bit of research or
something yeah yeah he was he was uh
doing some right investigation yeah
probably that's probably what it was and
and and I was trying to make sure it
didn't pop up on our screen but uh
inadvertently so there's basically I'm
trying to find this video I don't know
if I can but there was a video of a guy
uh you know two two Christian Bible
humping dudes uh who were sitting who
you know Bible porn I don't think I well
no basically he probably would judge he
was what I'm saying there was a man it
might have been on Instagram or
something but basically these two guys
were trying to how do you hump a Bible
I'm just oh dude they [ __ ] hump it
every day they go you're like oh this is
safe sex uh
I think what the I think with the video
that's some Godly [ __ ] right there
the video I'm trying to find it but I
can't find it but basically the idea is
that uh this guy was trying to blame
porn Okay like he was trying to blame
porn for white or like what Society is
doing for why he was looking at gay porn
instead of being like hey look I so it
wasn't so it wasn't it wasn't him that
was doing it it was Society was forcing
him to oh here we go here we go boom
found it
and then we'll go back to the punching
Nazi yeah yeah
okay so this guy is uh
uh it's a whole the whole thing anyway
yeah he doesn't take responsibility he
blames
society and what we've created for his
attraction to watching gay porn
so he's not actually
gay is what he's saying it's just okay
well let's let's let's this looks start
this starting off this already Bible
humping this already looks a little
weird
it it's two dudes in the video
with the word porn censored which I
don't why are they censoring the word
porn as if it's a bad word
I don't understand that what the [ __ ] is
that about I don't know we don't have to
watch the whole thing you can just watch
a few a little bit to get an idea of
what we're dealing with
this is why I had to actually completely
stop watching porn and stop playing
around with it
um
playing around with what does that even
mean amen I mean I watch porn do you
watch baby extensions I watch porn I
watch porn but what does that mean
playing around with porn it no well he
said playing around with it right well
is he talking about let's let's make
sure we get the quote right here
completely stop watching porn and stop
playing around with it stop playing
around with it but I'm assuming he's
saying porn but you might be assuming
he's who knows I don't know maybe he
maybe there's some sort of thing I just
don't know what that means you're like
watching porn do you play around with
Marvel movies like you watch Marvel I'm
loving I'm loving the man spreading
going on right now yeah that it is
really manly that's masculine the other
thing is the ominous the music that they
added to it gets a mood it goes up does
it okay yeah
um the porn I was watching gradually as
I watched over the years upon years it
just kind of got darker and darker and
the wax stuff I never thought I'd be
watching and I'm sure there's a lot of
you guys did he just refer to pouring as
wax stuff yeah yeah
because I mean honestly if you're a dude
and then maybe a woman's like this dude
but I can only speak for myself
if you're a dude it's all wack stuff
isn't it like yeah
the whole point I'm just saying I don't
know okay let's let's continue here guys
out there that are watching some porn
that is is something you never ever
thought you'd be watching
sixth grade
um the porn I jumped into some weird
categories man this is tough
sex with chicks okay so the music's
getting more and more ominous and then
he goes straight to and says did he say
in sixth grade he was watching roll it
back roll back a sec yeah okay so good
the porn I jumped into some weird
categories man this is tough
transgenders having sex with chicks and
transgenders having sex with you I'm
guessing he's saying transgender women
yeah yeah and again and again this is
nothing's wrong with that dude well
again you know whatever you want to
watch Whatever Gets your whack off you
know your this wax stuff you know that's
the whole point but here's the thing is
this I I've said this before time and
time again why like Matt Walsh and
Charlie Kirk and Ben shapir and all
these people who's Super Hyper focused
on other people's genitalia this is
exactly why they're hyper focused on it
they are terrified
terrified that they would like to watch
a woman who has a dick have sex
they are in there terrified that they
might pick up a woman at a bar find her
attractive the personality everything's
clicking you buy some drinks you might
go back to the hotel room together and
then you find out she's transgender and
it would just destroy your entire
masculinity and your straightness and it
sounds like that's what's going on in
this video a little bit yeah let's let's
continue why am I watching this stuff
well because I'm opening myself up to
spirits and Spirits the more I watch the
porn and I don't even realize
you know and as it gradually goes it
gets darker and I was watching
transgenders having sex with like
transgenders and then dudes and I'm like
why am I watching this stuff
okay so I just want to be clear
um anyone and I'm sure a lot of the
audiences search porn maybe some not as
many as others I've searched full
disclosure I've searched a lot of porn
before especially on PornHub but here's
the thing you do not have to go into a
certain category if you do not want to
now sometimes in you when you're
searching or when you're watching you
know there might be videos that they're
suggesting to you that pop up that you
don't really aren't interested in you
can scroll past those it's just like
YouTube you could get a recommendation
for a video based on what forcing you to
watch this content right I mean I don't
know what I don't know what porn site
this this guy's on but PornHub in
general which is like the you know um I
don't know who who brought up the
comment earlier about PornHub searching
but it's like the monster of of free
porn sites like that's where the
majority of the I'm sure searches
happens on the daily are minutely I mean
maybe maybe like the 10 secondly right
but what's what's so funny about PornHub
I know comedians who have released their
stand-up shows on Pornhub she has to get
the search results just to get people
watching you can [ __ ] stream the
PornHub I never thought about that I
wonder if they let us live stream there
I don't know maybe would anyone go and
watch us on PornHub no I'm dead serious
I'm being [ __ ] serious I would you
could I mean at one point I know
um uh kabel nanjiani who many people
he's a comedian
um uh he
he discovered I think it was like two
Christmases ago like 2020 or something
like that he found that
there was an illegal copy of the big
sick hit the movie that he wrote uh
which is about a somewhat
autobiographical like with the
relationship with his girlfriend right
right right right yeah yeah
um I've seen it it's a great movie yeah
great yeah
um and
he found he somebody told him I think on
Twitter was like oh there's a copy of
the big sick your movie on PornHub and
he was like oh my God and like retweeted
and commented and then PornHub was like
oh we'll take it down immediately he was
like no no no no
I yeah don't take it away from this
audience
all right all right I want people to
watch this listen I would I would
broadcast on PornHub
I'm sure that there's a time I mean here
somebody else said here there's a ton of
free movies on the Hub y'all so like hey
what's you know what I'm going to
investigate this week and maybe next
week we will broadcast line from PornHub
who knows that could be a whole whole
different whole another audience that is
available boom it was a Nikki Benz fan
yeah sure there you go
Nikki is Nikki's she's
she's got to be in the top 25 I'm not
saying I mean she's definitely my top 25
but I'm saying in general like because
that's the other thing they do on born
of is they rate you know right and it's
based on views and stuff right yeah they
also do it based on like how many people
are typing in those names I know we want
to talk about porn more I mean we're
here it's a it looks great it's running
out of time running out of time but
let's let's finish up these little sad
sacks of [ __ ] here how they don't
understand why they're liking to watch a
certain kind of porn it's because you
like it dude why and that's totally fine
it's not that big of a deal wrong with
that right there's nothing wrong with
that even if you want to watch gay porn
and not live you know that way it's okay
you can do that that's a thing you can
do you have the Liberty to do it let's
listen eventually the porn's not going
to be enough just like Ted bunny
eventually oh see here's the problem
this is the fear you started actually
this is it and I started doing the ACT
this is that see I ever thought I'd be
doing this is the Ben Shapiro mat wall
Tucker Carlson stuff that's my quick
short testimony on porn and how it just
dragged me to a dark place okay is he
had many also is he admitting the
hypothetical scenario that he was acting
something out or was he saying it took
him to another place and he did do he
did he's saying he did do dark stuff no
well he did he did yeah porn did not
make him do those things he did the
stuff that he saw in porn is what he's
saying
okay well really quickly I just want to
bring up earlier we brought up how this
whole idea of Nick Fuentes is the new
voice of the Republican party and we've
seen all these people you know whether
they denounce or they don't denounce or
they do this or they don't do that right
some people are future proofing
especially when it comes to Trump in
this scenario if people remember Richard
Spencer the Nazi uh and if you don't
remember him we have a clip to remind
you in a moment yeah yeah we'll yeah
we'll play that clip but in this clip
he's talking about how
uh
uh Donald Trump didn't actually who's
the badass that he's talking to here I
don't know who that guy is damn hang on
Ethan Ralph I guess I don't know Ethan
Ralph I want to set the tone kill stream
yeah I want to set the tone here
this is um what the [ __ ] okay let's
let's watch what do you think about
um
Trump not disavowing really uh Fuentes
this whole time
he can't I mean look he never really
disavowed me he never disavowed the
alt-right he never disavowed
Charlottesville I mean he doesn't
disavow his own people he might disavow
me now because I've been you know uh
anti-trump for five years or whatever it
is now four years
um he won't disavow his own people I
mean that that he does know who Butters
his bread and so yeah he's not going to
do it he kind of you know he said I
don't know who Nick Fuentes is
as MTG said you know shortly after
appearing at a Nick Fuentes concert or a
conference rather kind of like a concert
um so you know it was a deflection you
could say but I I just I don't think
he's going to do it and and I think if
he's forced to do it it would ultimately
be a weakness I I think any politician
that's any Republican that's denouncing
this stuff is going to lose
am I still there yeah you sure
okay it's not showing up on my any
Republican that denounces uh yay is
going to lose because they're ultimately
denouncing their own people
wow that's incredible and I think I'm
gonna wear sunglasses from now on
because it seems really weird yeah yeah
killstream what the hell yeah so uh
Richard Spencer he's a Nazi uh can you
take me seriously with these on I don't
I don't know dude I I feel like I feel
like I would catch you down in the lake
about to go tubing get on the jet ski
you know have a couple throw back a
couple Natty lights hey I that that
actually was a time in my life believe
it or not and that was a time in my life
get a couple Slim Jims yeah oh yeah oh
yeah let's never do a slim jim okay here
is if no one knows who Richard Spencer
is this will I'm just gonna mute it um
and we're gonna play it on Lou beer this
will refresh your memory
um of who he is he's showing yeah okay
yeah
oh [ __ ]
this is how you properly punch a Nazi a
lot of people are like you shouldn't
show
the show because it's violence
listen
I'm just saying that if you're going to
oh do something to a Nazi it might be
you know a consideration also I mean
look at look at the alternative right if
you were presented with a Nazi has some
crazy things supports Hitler says you
know Holocaust didn't happen or even
says yeah it did and we should kill more
Jewish people like that
are you going to tell me that if you
were presented with the option you're
like do I hit this person or do I not
hit this person if you say I don't want
to hit this person
I look at that and I say well where do
you where do you would you sit at the
table would you sit at the table with
them or would you not sit at the table
right like I I even look at like a like
a a pacifist and I might even think of
Passage like
wait wait wait one second
maybe maybe this is that better oh yeah
just trying to I'm testing this out yeah
okay uh everybody we are way past time
we're way past time with the porn and
the punching Nazis talk
um I want to say one more time
congratulations and welcome Brittany
Greiner
um as we she comes back uh to the to the
states and as a great victory for for
America today
um bringing Brittany Greiner back to the
United States also a great Victory
um for rights and Liberty in this
country today with where the house
passes the marriage quality Act
and then I'm sure it'll go to the
president's desk within the next few
days and he'll sign it
um so that uh that is a huge victory for
Liberty and a huge victory for America
it is not surprising that the Democratic
party is the one who delivered again
this this this victory for freedom and
liberty I mean it's also quite I mean if
you if you think about where Nancy
Pelosi started and what issues she
started on when she came into office and
now as she kind of you know hands off
the gavel or gives off the her you know
uh leadership position in the Democratic
party off to uh Jeffries you know you
think of like this is the last probably
one of the last bills that she'll be
able to pass through and hit the gavel
with and it being the marriage equality
act I think [ __ ] just says a lot
about what it shows it shows that
um that from the very beginning Nancy
Pelosi has been for equality and equity
and trying to use democracy in a way
that that it delivers that for anyone
and everyone that it can and hopefully
one of these days is all people Everyone
you are the best audience in the world
in I say world because you are watching
from around the world on YouTube Twitter
and twitch every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific also simulcasting from the minus
touch Facebook page don't forget to
follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels and also download every single
episode on Apple Spotify Google follow
us on Twitter because you're going to
get to vote for bone end of the week at
Tony Michaels podcast also make sure to
subscribe here on YouTube you can vote
there for bonehead of the week every
single week as tomorrow we will break
down your vote for bonehead of the week
in the second hour of the show just go
to the community tab once we get a
posted there you'll be able to put your
ballot in as Sean Hannity would say put
your ballot in for bonehead of the week
okay I'm sorry about the porn talk I'm
sorry about the sunglasses and I'm
definitely sorry about the Gabe Sanchez
weird tiny hand thing here everyone same
time same place tomorrow serves up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
foreign
[Music]